on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on PSG on sensed hundreds of
people are reportedly killed in an air
strike on a hospital in Gaza City
President Biden heads to Israel tomorrow
as it forces prepare a deadly ground
Invasion I'll talk live to bassm MF and
we'll debate how can Israel be
proportionate about Terror also tonight
Prof fighter Dylan danis lost his big
money bouncing bout to the YouTuber
Logan Paul can he bounce back and what's
he got to say and how does he look I'll
talk to him
[Music]
exclusively live from the news building
in London this is Pierce Morgan
uncensored well good evening from London
welcome to Piers Morgan on sensor the
parallels between 911 and last week's
atrocities in Israel are painfully
obvious these were murderous terrorists
religious Fanatics who killed with
barbaric impunity on Sovereign land as I
said yesterday the proportion of the
Israeli population murdered in these
attacks was equivalent to 30,000
Americans being killed on us soil it's
no wonder Israel is expect a strong
response and Israel as I keep saying has
every right to defend itself from Hamas
going forward but the aftermath of 911
taught us some tough lessons too Across
the Western World there was a fervor for
Revenge
President Bush spoke for many when he
said
this I can hear
you I can hear you the rest of the world
hears you and the
people and the people who knock these
buildings down will hear all of us
soon with popular rhetoric with that
yearning for justice to commer America
and its allies including Britain into a
trap first G the war on terror in
Afghanistan lasted 20 years cost more
than $2 trillion to countless lives and
ultimately ended with the Taliban back
in charge of the country next came the
illegal invasion of Iraq which had
nothing much to do with Bin Laden or
Al-Qaeda and turned into a disaster more
than a million died Iraq became a
breeding ground for Isis a my superious
excuse for the war but Saddam Hussein
had weapons of mass destruction turned
out to be a credibility slaying lie well
the situation is very different but the
potential perils are the same there's no
dispute that Hamas committed these
attacks because they they've repulsively
boasted about it and threatened more but
a full-blown invasion of Gaza will be
horribly difficult to execute retired
General David betrus who commanded
Allied Forces in Iraq describes it like
this I almost can't imagine a more
challenging contextual set of
circumstances here than what they face
there are tunnels there will will be
rooms that will have improvised
explosive devices you have to clear
every building every floor every room
every basement every tunnel civilian
losses are inevitable and tough Israeli
losses lie ahead as well well civilian
deaths are sadly inevitable that is the
Grim reality of War if Israel gets this
wrong it could turn into a long deadly
and much expanded War which fuels the
next generation of terrorists and
unleashes Chaos across the whole region
Palestinian authorities already say that
more than 3,000 civilians have been
killed by Israeli air strike since last
week tonight the Hamas controlled
authorities in Gaza say a hospital has
been blown up and what they say was an
Israeli air strike that up to 500 people
could have died if it turns out to be
true and there are conflicting reports
as I came on air that it may have been a
misfired Hamas rocket so we'll have to
wait for verification on this then it
could be a massive turning point in this
war every day now the civilian death
toll is going to climb it will Skyrocket
of course with any ground Invasion and
every image like the ones we're seeing
tonight will pile more pressure on
Israel to show restraint to be
proportionate I'll be honest I don't
know what a proportionate response is to
what happened on October the 7th how can
anything be proportionate to the murder
of babies in their beds to the slaughter
of 260 people in a music festival to the
kidnapping of a holocaust Survivor and
198 other hostages to the burning aive
of innocent families together in their
homes I honestly don't have the answer
to that question but it's one that
Israel will have to ask your and soon
well joining me now to discuss the
conflict in Israel and Gaza it's a TV
host in Satur Bassam YF Bassam it's
great to have you back on the program I
wish it was under different
circumstances um first of all what is
your reaction to What happened on
October the
7th oh it was terrible of course I mean
we kind of get our news kind of also
secondhand because you know my my wife's
family they live in Gaza they they have
uh cousins and uncles there um and uh
their house also was bombed we haven't
been able to communicate with them for
the past three days communication are
lost so we don't know actually what is
the uh how is like how are they're doing
but you know we're used to that I mean
it's it just like it's it's it's very
repetitive we used to that we used to
them being bombed every time and moving
from one place to the other uh you know
it's just like those Palestinians
they're very dramatic ah Israel killing
us but they never die I mean they always
come back you know they they're very
difficult to kill very difficult people
to kill I know because I'm married to
one I tried many times couldn't kill her
I mean there's a dark humor there and I
understand why because no it's not dark
hum I really I try to get to her every
time but she uses our kids as human
Shields I can never take her
out again I understand the the human but
I to be serious basam about this tonight
there is okay I will be serious no I I I
I will be serious I was watching your
interview with Ben Shapiro and I'll will
tell you one thing I think that Ben
Shapiro is one of the smartest people
who ever walked this Earth he's very
very smart I follow him and I believe
everything he said and when he came out
on your show his solution was and I
quote his solution was that the solution
for this is for Israel to Annex Gaza and
to kill as many son of [__] as
possible to make sure that this will
never happen again and anyone anyone who
call for a ceasefire will be a terrorist
sympathizer so God forbid I don't want
to be labeled as a terrorist sympathizer
so I agree with Ben shapir I think we
should kill as many son of [__] as
possible so
far so far 3,500 people were killed
including 5,000 son of [__] in the
bombing of the Baptist uh uh uh hospital
as we speak right now onethird of those
3,500 were children so my question to
Ben Shapiro is how many more son of
[__] do we need to kill so Ben
Shapiro is happy because it changes from
changes from I'm I'm I'm sorry that
listen I'm I'm I'm really at a
disadvantage here I'm looking at a
camera I don't see you I can hear you on
my the reason I'm interrupting is I
think you might be I think I think
you're conflating different interviews
with bench ofir he didn't use the phrase
sons of [__] with me let me play to
you what he actually said on my he did
he did good
go back to your interview he didn't that
was another interview but let me play
what he said to me
here well I frankly I don't believe in
proportionate response to terrorism I
believe that the way that you stop
terrorism is with wildly
disproportionate response that doesn't
mean in terms of targeting civilians it
means in terms of killing as many
terrorists as humanly possible and
allowing them to dictate the terms of
Engagement by hiding behind civilians in
areas that that they are supposedly
responsible for means that the only
option for Israel is to surrender to
hamas's hatred of its own citizens its
willingness to use its own children as
human Shields no no country worth it
salt could ever do that now that is sign
substantively different to what you said
he said right he's talking there
specifically about agree with him I
agree I I I agree with him the the thing
is the question is what is a
proportionate response because it has
been different from one tier to other so
if you look to this graph for example
this is the death of Israeli and
Palestinians and it's changing from one
year to year it's like fluctuating like
crypto so my question is today what is
the going rate to day for human lives I
mean 2014 was a great year for Ben
chapiro 88 Israelis were died and there
was
2329 Palestinians killed on the other
side that is one Israeli for 27 uh
Palestinian that is a very good exchange
rate what I'm saying is what is the
exchange rate for today so you guys will
be happy that's my question well it's
not me it's not me guys I I I'm not on
either side not you like when I say you
guys I say like the people on the other
side of that I know that you you don't
think like that appears you one of the
good guys but let me tell you something
I mean I'm the reason that I'm I'm using
this is that I mean I could I can't
remember what happened in 2014 and there
was no music festival but there there
must be something I mean they must do
something it is their fault it has to be
something I mean 2018 300 Palestinian
died ah who's counting you know so the
thing is what my question is let's find
what is the exchange rate for human life
today so we know expect the fure future
death of Palestinians and will be happy
to it my my response to that would be
this B I thought carefully about this
because I think it's very tricky for
people like me to immerse ourselves into
a conflict where we're not directly
involved and I thought carefully about
what I feel about this I feel that the
scale of what Hamas did on October the
7th supersedes anything else I've seen
in this conflict really ever that the
the savagery The Butchery the slaughter
of 1300 people the shooting of babies
the kidnapping of grandmother and so on
so if if we can agree on that which I
think is inarguable then the question
then becomes again about proportion I I
don't disagree that there's been a lot
of bad stuff on both sides going back
historically for decades but if we agree
that this was on a different level
altogether quite deliberately by Hamas
designed designed to provoke designed to
here my question let me ask you a
question and and the question you you
raised it earlier about proportion I
honestly don't know what the
proportionate response is uh I I I
honestly don't I I don't I've been
watching the air strik what's your
question well I was asked I well I would
ask you if you were Israel what would
you was Israel if you were Israel and
that had happened to you what would you
think would be the appropriate way for
the country to respond I would do
exactly like Israel did Kill as many
people as possible since the the the
word is letting me do it I mean I I can
do it because I can you know but but the
thing is you know what I agree with you
and you know what I'm going to be even
ahead of you because I see the question
coming do you condemn Hames for the atro
yes I condemn Hames I condemn Hamas I
condemn Hamas is the source of all evil
there for and you know what let's for a
minute imagine a world without Hamas
right what will this word look like
let's give this word a name and let's
name this word the West Bank Hamas has
absolutely no control in the West Bank
and since the beginning of this stre
only through August 37 pales kids were
killed no music festival no paragliding
no Hamas since the occupation of the
West Bank 7,000 Palestinians were killed
no music festival no paragliding no
Hamas I can go on and on and on and
on because in a way in a way you're
preaching to the choir i' I've followed
this crisis Oh no you're not preaching
so the thing is like sense I know I know
that what you're saying has validity of
course of course Pier Pierce by the way
Pier Pierce Pierce I am at a
disadvantage here I can hear you I
cannot see you I am in a claustrophobic
room and so please cut me some slack and
don't interrupt me and interrupt my
points sure so because this this this
has to be fair because if you want to
only hear your opinion I can just
condemn Hames and go home I can do that
so if you do you want to do that or do
you have a much more Nuance conversation
no I absolutely want to have a Nuance
conversation I wasn't aware I was
interrupting you I amazing so let's I
mean I mean I would say I would say I
really applaud Israel for doing one
thing that no military force in the
world does because I heard I heard Ben
Shapiro and I heard Rond santis and they
said they said Israel is the only
military force in the world that warns
civilians before bombing them I mean how
[__] cute that is so nice of them
because with this logic if Russian
troops started warning ukrainians before
bombing their houses we're cool with
Putin right I mean okay Habibi you have
warned them go invade it's fine you have
done your job job I mean the thing is
and I understand and I also heard Ben
Shapiro talking about uh about human
shield so you remember my wife's family
they live in Gaza so I asked them I told
them when Israel give you the nice
warning the cute warning does Hamas
force you to stay in your home so you
can be bombed and use a as as human
shield you know what Hass here my my
wife's uh my wife's cousin he's a he's
he's a loser you know he he told me you
know when I asked him does that happen
he told me no the lying son of a [__]
lied to me I told him you don't
understand Ben Shapiro and Rond santis
keep saying that Israel warns you and
Hamas asked you to keep to stay put so I
I I told you he's a loser he never kept
a job he even like failed in all of the
interviews to become like a human shield
I I I would believe Ben shapir let ask
so let's go with that no no no let's no
no let me ask you at some point I must
be to ask question it's
not if we agree if we agree the the 14th
,000 casualties I mean who's counting
are human shield does that mean that
every single one of those civilians was
standing obscuring a military Target
behind them because that's a lot of
weapons I mean Hamas is packing no of
course it doesn't and look I you know it
do so so so there is some collateral
damage lots of collateral damage yes
it's fine yeah you kill you kill some to
save some and then kill some more yeah I
agree yeah yeah yeah I would let me ask
you this again it comes back to
proportionate response when the world
when the world decided it had to get rid
of Isis because of the appalling
Butchery they were carrying out uh it
did so by by also killing very sadly a
lot of civilians along the way by doing
air strikes against places which killing
civilians are in said that in the
beginning point it's inevitable but once
Israel once Israel has decided that they
want to get rid of Hamas and Hamas is
embedded with cilian population I'm very
concerned about what's going to happen
next I've written a column tonight
saying I remember
which I oppos right I remember all this
so my question for you is what would be
what would you think would be an
appropriate response by Israel to what
happened well well the these are years
of disproportionate responses of Israel
did it solve the solution did it solve
the problem did did it work before so it
will what what will be the surprise this
time what will be the twist that will
make this work this time what what will
be different this time seriously I mean
like this is only the last 15 years I
mean because it's too too many PE papers
I just got this but what how will this
will be different and the thing is it I
am so glad in the introduction that you
mentioned the Iraq War I applaud you
Pier for saying that because you were
honest about it you said that spreading
lies like wmds make people look at those
people as less of humans and they would
accept the death of a million Iraqi
whether by sh sanctions or by Invasion
right you are you you are a good man
this is amazing and you know what is
similar is when you spread the lies of
40 decapitated babies although it was
refuted so what happens when people hear
that you know killing babies is horrible
but when you say decapitated 40 babies
you are planting a certain image a
certain trigger in people's mind who has
said that who has said 4 said that you
have said 40 decapitate who has said
that you have you have repeat no no I
haven't what I've never said that you
haven't said on your show 40 decapitated
babies never Ben Pi didn't say it Ronda
Sanz didn't say it nobody has said okay
P nobody said it no oh okay okay maybe I
am wrong decapitated here you're wrong
I've never said that the thing what
happened what yeah well no you're you're
wrong but the thing is when Iraq the
thing is the same thing is happening in
Iraq Ben Shapiro once tweeted not even
about Gaza about the West Bank when
Israel continued to build the illegal
set he said 2017 Israel likes to build
things and Arabs not Palestine not Hamas
Arabs like the bomb crap and live in
open sewage yeah I thought that was very
very isra the Israeli defense the isra
defense minister he said those are human
animals and the thing is Ben shapir
should know better because you know long
before the Holocaust before Jewish
people were thrown in the gas
Chambers the Nazi propaganda called them
rats now as a human being I will never
accept that another human being being
thrown in a into a g chamber but a rat
kill a 10 kill a thand 3,500 they are
son of a bit they are human animals who
live in open sewage and decapitate
babies and because of that propaganda Mr
Morgan that guy in Illinois the 71 years
old guy he killed stabbing the six years
old Palestinian kid in Ino 26 times and
he used to play with him they used to be
friends but he went in marching into
their apartment stabbing his mother and
killing him shouting all Muslims could
die it took you8 years to change one
word from Jewish to Muslim and then you
transferred your guilt to us and took
away our land let me ask let me ask you
a question that deal sucks man let me
ask you a question uh how do we get from
where we are now to
peace well first of all you need to
change the perception uh Nikki Haley the
American presidential candidate said we
are in Israel in this because it's a
fight between EV Good and Evil now if
you already decided someone is good he
can do no evil and if you decided
someone is evil it's good to kill them
killing them is good you see the thing
is it is it is not like something new I
mean I I I look at history and I see I'm
sorry to say and I'm sorry to say this
but westerners has always dealt like
this with indigenous people you first
treated them like Savages you know
Native American First Nation Aboriginal
they're Savages kill all the Savages and
then when they almost extinct you start
feeling sorry for them you know like
animals so maybe maybe the solution is
that we kill as many Palestinians as
possible so the few of them that remains
do not bother you and maybe talking for
another 100 years become a tree hugger
let me just challenge you on this and he
will campaign for for preserving the
keep talking about westerners like me
okay so let me return the favor okay
Hamas is dedicated to the complete
eradication of Jewish people I am not
the spokesman for H why do you why do
you spokesman [__] hate them [__]
ham are you happy you're missing my
point you're talking in a generalized
way about people in the west who always
talk about Arabs as Savages I don't no
no no I'm
talking actually the campaign I led the
media campaign in this country against
the Iraq War okay so I don't see I don't
see people in the Middle East savages
the good ones but what I say talking
about you you're great no no it's not
about me being it's about it's about the
way Hamas behaved on October the 7th was
like Savages like a pack of savages it
was the worst atrocity against Jewish
people since the Holocaust there has to
be of there has to be a response and my
question beic my question for you ising
the history B what is the proportionate
response but I don't know but there's no
Hamas in the West Bank and there's still
lying there so what's your excuse I
don't have any
excuse okay what's what's your
explanation sorry sorry uh my earpiece
went down I I listen I don't make any
pretense that this hasn't been a massive
problem okay between Palestine and
Israel going back to the mid-40s we all
know this right I I'm I'm I'm yeah yeah
yeah Pierce Pierce Pierce listen I'm not
saying that you're making excus but if
you are adopting a certain point of view
you have to at least defend it I'm
telling you there is no Hamas in the
West Bank what is what is the excuse not
your excuse what is the excuse to kill
those
people well it's listen this question of
proportionality is one that no no no
answer my question I've been answering
your question you answer mine it's
actually not my job to answer your
questions it's not okay not your not
your job I I I agree with you I'm more
interested in you who has family in Gaza
who's an A in the Middle East right I'm
more interested in what you have to say
okay I'm telling you I'm telling you
think Hamas is the problem okay now
let's say Hamas is removed let's ham
yeah I I I'm agreeing with everything
about I you want me to go Hamas I will
condemn Hamas hus Hass everybody guys
say wait I can't hear you the uh the
earpiece damn okay
oops okay yeah uh I I do need I think I
think just go go back is he there you go
back you go back go back okay go thank
you guys can you hear yeah yeah now I
can hear so here's the thing can you
hear okay so is let's say for example
Hamas ceased to exist okay do you hear
me yes yeah Hamas ceased to exist today
now right now in Palestine in West Bank
and and uh and Gaza 20% of Palestinians
go through Israeli prison system whether
imprisonment whether interrogation
whether torture and the rest of them
they live a life of daily loss of land
of homes of life and they are they are
suffocated by the so let me ask you
something if you are a Palestinian
living into these conditions for decades
would you would you sympathize with your
oppressor or sympathize with the people
who claim they resist them even if they
are terrorists I have made I have made
no secret that I think the conditions
Palestinians have had to exist under are
completely unacceptable I've said that
for years so the question then becomes
how do you forge peace between two
Waring parts of that region who for
decades have approached peace in my view
with mutual sledgehammers with no actual
desire to have peace and I think it
comes down in the end to great
leadership and I I don't think there's
great leadership I don't think well hang
on let me make my point I don't think
there's great leadership on either side
where is the Nelson Mandela figure here
to come through all this hat on both
Mandela where is that
Mandela NE Nelson Mandela actually have
criticized Israel for being a horrible
State all of the South African activist
have actually Israel my point is about
how he how he responded to a country
that was so divided is a temp is a
template is a template for how you get
to peace isn't it I I I I haven't met
Danon Mandela so I wouldn't know but
like I I I there is a point there's a
there's a very important Point here you
know I want to understand what is the
logic of Israel carpet boming Gaza I
mean if there's a logic if there's a
good if this will make Israel safe I
want to hear the logic so if they
continue bombing what are they hoping to
achieve we know what their we know what
their stated aim is their stated aim is
to eradicate and wipe out Hamas they
believe Hamas are living are living
predominantly in Northern Gaza they also
are aware they're living amongst
civilians so it's an incredibly
difficult thing as I said as I said in
my you know it is very very difficult to
see how they do this without massive
collateral damage
so if I can understand this correctly
basically Israel is doing this to
pressure the Palestinian community in
Gaza to turn against Hamas is that right
I'm sure that's part of it yes that's
part of it so this is exactly what
terrorist organization do because
terrorist organizations will have no
chance beating a whole nation in battle
so they terrorize and they kill the
civilians in order to spread fear and
Terror so they can turn against their
government to change their policy or to
resign you have just compared Israel
with Isis no I haven't I don't I don't
see any comparison between it's going to
be the headlines tomorrow Israel is Isis
only only amongst people who weren't
listening the comparison which is more
apite is Isis and Hamas they are both
nihilistic Terror groups intent on
killing as many Jewish people and others
as they can possibly kill and you can't
you can't you can't get peace with
people like that absolutely you know
what I'm going to do something that
nobody done on your television you know
what I'm going to do on your episode I'm
I'm going to do I'm going to pretend
that I'm an Israeli citizen I'm going to
put my my myself in the in the place of
an Israeli settler in the kaputs and I
want to speak to my prime minister
Benyamin nany Mr Benyamin Netanyahu I
have voted for you because you have
promised us peace and prosperity and
security on the 7th of October those son
of [__] Hamas they went into defense
that is regularly heavy heavily guarded
usually usually if there's like a dove
that comes close to it it will be shot
those people went in and they went for
six hours before IDF forces was deployed
killing our friends our families
kidnapping our grandmothers and babies
and went in I want to ask you Mr Prime
Minister after you have fractured the
Israeli community and you have [__]
our courts our Supreme Courts what are
you doing with the money being given to
you to the United States also you are
carpet bombing Gaza with absolutely no
regard to our hostages our people I
heard a rumor in the kaputs that you're
doing that as an you let that happen to
as an excuse to carpet bomb Gaza so you
push them into Sinai and I didn't
believe that I like not my prime
minister he can never do that and then I
watched an interview for Danny Alon he
was your Chief advisor he was also the
Israeli ambassador to the United States
and you know what he said Mr Prime
Minister he said that the solution for
those Palestinians is to go into a vast
land of Sinai and live into tent cities
temporarily huh temporarily wink wink
until we build Gaza again and then we
invite you
back we've seen this movie before so and
I and when I saw this I couldn't explain
to my fellows in the Kuts how come our
Israeli government is trading human
lives for another piece of land so as an
Israeli citizen I need to hold my
Israeli government accountable and as an
American citizen I want to know all of
these money that we are giving to Israel
we giving them $4 billion every year Joe
Biden said it's the best investment they
ever America ever done well I if I am in
the in the place of Joe Biden I would
say sorry don't speak
uh I I would I would say if I was Joe
Biden I would go down and whisper in the
ears of Nano and tell them I hate bad
Investments they haunt me you know like
little finger in Game of Thrones but the
thing is the thing I think is this is
the problem Israel always victimizes
itself and I have never seen a victim
putting their oppressor Under Siege and
bombing them 24/7 Israel wants you to
believe that they are the victim dealing
with Israel is so difficult it's like
being in a relationship with a
narcissistic psychopath he [__] you up
and then he makes you think it's your
fault you look at Israel as Superman but
they're really homelander they are like
they they are
shooting and they are annoyed with the
splashes B I want to say two things one
if you could just slightly Mound your
language we are uncensored but if you
keep swearing we have to apologize to
viewers you may be offended by that but
I understand passions Run High so let's
not get too bugged down about the oldd
swear I apologize to the viewers I
apologize to the viewers for my language
my second question is this after site of
of dead civilian after the break we have
the managing director of The Daily wire
which is Ben Shapiro's company we were
going to interview him on his own but
he's happy to come on and talk with you
directly if you are prepared to stay
well of course I I I can stay but again
I am [__]
this I am in a disadvantage and I would
like to have my space to respond okay
we'll come back after the break I I I
because because because here's the thing
there we got to go to a break when we
come back from the break be you and
Jeremy B my my I have new we're taking a
short break B I'll be
[Music]
back
[Applause]
[Music]
e
welcome back to on senson for more on
the situation in Israel I'm joined now
by the CEO and co-founder of the daily
wi Ben Shapiro's partner Jeremy boring
uh Jeremy thank you very much indeed for
joining me I'm sorry we demoted you
earlier to Mia MD you are the CEO and
co-founder uh you know Ben Shapiro
better than anyone really I did a big
interview with Ben obviously the other
night um which went around the world um
and has sparked a big reaction including
from uh Our Guest Bassam youf who's
still with us first of all you've been
listening to to Bassam and what he's
been saying what's your
response well first of all I make it a
point not to speak for Ben Shapiro he's
got a 20 IQ points on me and speaks for
a living professionally so he's much
better prepared to defend himself but as
his business partner as his best friend
I I do feel like I have to respond to
the things that bosam was just saying
uh first of all the question of how many
sons of [__] have to be killed in
order to end this conflict I suppose
that the answer is as many of them as it
takes that doesn't mean that I or Ben or
any decent person in their right mind is
happy with the killing of civilians uh I
posted at the very beginning of this
conflict that a a woman or a child blown
apart in Gaza is just as tragic as a
Jewish baby killed in one of the
settlements that doesn't mean that
Israel's actions and the actions of
Hamas are morally equivalent you know
the tragedy is the tragedy but the moral
equivalency is nonsense if you if you
entered Israel with the express purpose
of targeting and murdering civilians
with your own hands and cold blood that
is not comparable to Israel bombing
targets and the Gaza Strip and killing
civilians is a terrible tragic
consequence war war is terrible war is
an awful thing that's why decent people
don't lightly engage in War and why
Hamas should not have incited this war
you know we can talk about the history
of the Israeli conflict I'm not a
professional political commentator I'm a
I'm a CEO I'm a
screenwriter uh and I'm certainly not
Ben Shapiro I'm not here to discuss the
history of the Israeli Palestinian
conflict but we all saw what happened on
October 7th and the idea that Israel was
not going to react severely to that or
that Israel should not react severely to
that is ludicrous and the let
Meo should be a moderating voice that
Ben Shapiro should be what saying no
Israel should not respond in the
situation that's nonsense let me ask you
though Jeremy what I mean the question
which I think is the big question what
is a proportionate response to that
outrage on October the 7th which is the
worst attack on Jewish people since the
Holocaust what is proportionate if it's
true as reports are suggesting tonight
that there may have been a hospital hit
by an Israeli strike and up to 500
people or more have died that would seem
to me if that is verified and it's not
verified yet you know we don't know
exactly what has happened other than
there's been a hit on this hospital but
if that is verified to have been an
Israeli strike that will strike many
people as
disproportionate certainly well first of
all I don't know what a proportionate
response is or why we would want it I
suppose a proportionate response would
be for 3,000 Israelis to go through the
fence gun down innocent Palestinian
women and children burn their bodies
burn them alive take hostages rape their
women no one wants a proportionate
response no no moral person could
possibly call for a proportionate
response the purpose of war is to defeat
your enemy the West W has in my lifetime
forgotten the purpose of War because the
true cost of war is so terrible the last
time the West engaged in war and won it
was World War II and they did it through
incredible brutality they did it by
bringing their enemies to heal that is
not a thing to that's not a thing to rah
rah about that's not a thing to look
forward to as I said all decent people
should avoid war but I think the sort of
lie of the postor War II the post-war
consensus lie is that somehow War uh in
which you kill a bunch of people and
don't secure Victory is morally Superior
to war where you do secure Victory I
would say that the only way to morally
justify a war is to win it otherwise
your AR the very argument that brought
you into the war this enemy must be
defeated ends up being proven a lie I
mean Afghanistan I think America had
every right to go into Afghanistan uh
the Taliban was harboring Osama Bin
Laden and al- Qaeda al- Qaeda flew
planes into buildings in the United
States killed thousands of our citizens
brought the nation into Untold Agony
pain and horror America had every right
morally to go in and destroy the Taliban
and Destroy al- Qaeda but I would ARG
the Taliban now but the Taliban now
rules in Afghanistan the war was not won
but that's my point actually I've done a
column about this tonight uh for the sun
here in the UK which is I I was editor
of a newspaper when the Iraq War
happened I uh opposed it very
aggressively as the editor of the paper
um and sadly we were borne out by events
it was a complete disaster the Iraq War
in my view it was illegally contested I
think um and the consequences were
appalling in terms of loss of life a
million people in terms of Isis being
allowed to breed and create their merry
hell around the world in terms of
complete dismantling of of Iraq itself
as a as a functioning country uh and I
think Afghanistan again 20 years of you
know attacking an enemy which is now
running the country again seemed to me
again to be kind of pointless and I do
wonder whether Israel in its Blind Fury
which I completely understand has
thought through the consequences of
actually launching a full air ground and
sea offensive into Gaza as to actually
what happens at the end of that well I
suppose Israel wasn't really given the
opportunity to fully contemplate what
the consequences of that action might be
because Israel didn't instigate this war
this war was instigated by a horrible
terrorist attack on Israel and a state
is put in a position where it has to
respond now one might argue that the
very fact that Israel has yet to
actually launch their ground Invasion
means that they are actually making a
calculation about what the cost will be
what victory looks like any rational
person any decent person can engage in a
conversation about what is the
appropriate response for Israel of
course they can but this sort of moral
equivalency thing I don't think is a
sign of decency to engage in a
conversation about moral equivalency let
me bring uh bassim back in you've been
listening to this Bassin what's your
response to what Jeremy's been saying
I'm I'm sorry I didn't catch gentleman's
name it's Jeremy boring he's the chief
executive of the daily wire co-founder
with Ben Shapiro of the daily wire hi
Jeremy please say hello to Ben Shapiro
and please tell him that I do think he
is the smartest person to ever walk the
earth thank you so much so as response
to Jeremy uh I I I I I agree with
everything you said I mean what is
disproportionate I mean that you he just
used the uh examples from second world
war in America showing that civilian
casualty is a I mean I I heard his voice
he was very sad and he as he was telling
us it is so inevitable to kill so many
civilians because it's something that we
cannot avoid I hear the sadness in his
voice and I know that it's a very
difficult decision to kill all of these
civilians because that's for a higher
cast and I understand but my question I
I have two questions the question is how
can you justify The Killing In The West
Bank where Hamas does not exist and if
the disproportionate response during the
all of these years have actually worked
what will be new this time that did not
happen before I just want to that that
that was my question okay that question
I'm so so so now so now now if I ask the
question can I can I say something on my
side B with respect you Bassam with
respect I gave you half the show to have
your side Jeremy's had a lot less time
uh I'm going to have to you want me to
leave B I'm going to have to I'm going
to have to let you go because we've been
on there with you for 40 minutes okay
bye bye but listen byebye I would like
to talk to you again and thank you for
joining the program I appreciate it oh
by by by the way my my my wife's family
is is all right and they send us a house
it's it's bombed it's beautiful it's
it's going to be a good uh uh like
Halloween theme so well I'm very sorry
for what your family are going through
in Gaza and I mean by the way I don't
know I I don't know my I don't know him
by the way I don't I haven't actually
met them they didn't even come to my
wedding they couldn't because they are
stuck in Gaza and she never saw them
because you know Gaza is not a
destination we hear their voices and
it's uh they they die it's fine it's
fine Bassam I wish your family all the
very best thank you for joining me I
appreciate it I I don't thank you
Jeremy's going to stay with us and we're
going to be joined by the pack after the
break and we'll talk to Jeremy about
some other stuff connected with this
[Music]
story good evening I'm P Morgan
uncensored in New York City King pi and
King C I think there's only room for one
king man you know what I'm saying he's
mocked your weight Trump yeah look at
him fail not working just cuz they're
skin folk don't mean they're kin folk do
you believe you can win this war you
making me cry again they're trying to
force you out yes I feel betray keep it
awardwinning m Lucy Ley will die behind
bars and a senior Doctor Who first
raised concerns about Ley once NHS
manages to be regulated we needed
answers a lot sooner this is what 7
years down the line I mean it's it's
completely ludicrous he was clearly
something of the face of the ward so
even more Unthinkable if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katy that would make her a
better princess of wealth cuz you're not
just marrying the man you're marrying
the job that resonates with people gay
Maxwell agreed to be interviewed for the
very first time oh he wish I'd never met
him the conservative party can certainly
win the next election can we lab 29 in
the can we did he say yes I have taken
drugs and they bent the rules or lied on
the visa application form and therefore
got it there needs to be an intervention
around abortion laws Parliament is
Sovereign Parliament can determine these
things the rest of the world has watched
on in sort of mounting horror as this
story has unraveled for you it was
incredibly personal the death toll from
the Titanic tragedy has risen to 1522
and may God Rest their
[Music]
souls Let It
Roll if we stop producing oil the knock
on effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know now you're probably going to
boot me off CH and
this about Mark some of them they're
easily
lit you can kiss my American
ass thank you very much very nice of you
Twitter you sons of can you please
reinstate my account thank you that's a
threat that you'd be worried of it so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with
us we're now in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the Grand
jurry I'm the only one that has been
telling the truth you don't drink never
taken drugs you're stinking Rich should
you be
concerned if it's on your mind it's on
talk TV it's about you and your opinions
if you're thinking about it we're
talking about
it it's all about me that a
[Music]
joke this is talk
TV
welcome back to on S we still with me is
the CEO and co-founder of the daily wide
Jeremy boring I'm joined by my pack the
author and socialist Grace Blakeley to
to a contributor Paul Ron Adrian and the
journalist and author Hillary Freeman
who I'll come to all three of you in a
moment Jeremy I just want to talk to you
just pivot slightly I read a column for
the New York Post yesterday about this
kind of fical situation in America where
universities like Harvard who were
literally just named the worst school in
America for failure to ex exercise free
speech on campus now saying that the
reason they allowed their students to
all sign this absurdly offensive letter
in the immediate aftermath of these
attacks effectively siding with Hamas uh
was because of their Devotion to free
speech and the reason I think it's
relevant for you to answer that is I
know that you as a company you're
producing your own children's content to
counter the left and woke propaganda and
so on so it kinds to me there's a
there's a neat link here but what are
you making of what's been happening in
these universities in America I think
that the universities are in many ways
victims of their own rhetoric you one of
the dangerous things to do in life is to
say things out loud because pretty soon
you'll have to defend them and soon
after that you'll start to believe them
and Harvard has been preaching this sort
of intersectional hierarchy now for at
least a decade and maybe more the
problem with the intersectional
hierarchy is that someone has to be on
the bottom in the in the sort of name of
equality or fostering some sort of
better sense of equality they've created
a situation where you know people who
they see as having been historically in
places of power now are at the very
bottom and have been completely
dehumanized and one of the funny quirks
is they think that that is sort of
anti-majoritarian
anti-patriarchy you know in America it's
anti- Christian white male in
particular and that it protects
minorities but of course one of the
smallest minorities in the world is the
Jews and unfortunately in every other
way they seem to fit more in positions
of power they tend to excel acad Al they
tend to excel in business they're
disproportionately represented in media
in education in science you know in
traditionally white collar and
governmental type roles and so the
intersectional hierarchy being preached
by these schools has left them in a
position where you know the most
probably hard done by minority of the
20th and 21st century somehow has been
dehumanized by them and they don't know
how to get out of the way of their own
bad extraord there was actually a
professor at Cornell who was called on
camera doing
this I think we have it Hamas has
shifted the balance of power
yeah Hamas has
punctured the
illusion of
invincibility that's what they've done
it was
exhilarating resistance life it was
exhilarating it was energizing
exhilarating and energizing that's a
professor at a top American University
and I found that completely shocking a
that he would have that thought process
but be you would be so brazenly free to
do it in public like that well sure I
mean if what that Professor had said
instead is that gender and biological
sex are inextricably linked he'd be out
on the streets by now and never work
again instead he says that it's
exhilarating to watch children murdered
in their homes because of some sort of
bizarre academic theory about power
structures here's here's the thing
strength does not necessarily connote
virtue but strength also does not
necessarily connote a lack of virtue
weakness does not confer upon a person
virtue any more than weakness confers
upon a person a lack of virtue there are
wonderful Jews in the world and there
are terrible Jews in the world there are
wonderful Muslims in the world and there
are terrible Muslims in the world there
are wonderful people in positions of
strength I think the West is an a
relatively extraordinary job compared to
other societies throughout human history
and there are terrible people in
positions of we need only look to the
ruling regime in China among others to
know that when you collectivism is you
forget about the individual right we
know a lot of this obviously starts from
childhood you as a company have decided
to take on this what you see is the
indoctrination by the woke left of kids
tell me just briefly about that yeah
well I think that one of the things that
we at the daily wire feel is that
childhood uh has been sort of distorted
on one hand we have this University
system as you were just discussing that
infantilizes adults we refer to 23
three-year-olds as college kids and we
treat them like that like kids who
aren't responsible who have no agency
who can't be held accountable for their
own actions on the other hand we have
actual children actual kids and instead
of letting them live in a world of
imagination and adventure and joy and
wonder we want to use them as political
props we want to March them in our
rallies uh we want to hold them up as
some sort of symbol of the struggle
against you know entrenched power
structures or whatever the the invogue
terms are and what we believe at the
daily wire is actually why don't we let
adults be adults incl including 23 year
olds and why don't we let children be
children and so we've launched this
initiative bent key which is our new
company our new app and it's just
entertainment for kids it's not overtly
political we're overtly political as a
company of course but our content at
bent key is not it really is just a
place where kids can sit down actually
enjoy entertaining content and parents
don't have to worry about having these
sort of destructive ideas you know
Jeremy I've got four kids and I I say
hurrah to that honestly do I'm sick and
tired of these kids getting grabbed by
people who think they know what's best
for what these kids should be thinking
and doing it's it's ridiculous uh I've
got to leave it there Jeremy you've been
brilliant thank you very much indeed for
rolling with the the punches earlier you
came on to talk about this and we then
brought you into to respond to what
Bassam mus said I think that was
important and I I really appreciate
thank you very much thank you okay uh
Hillary welcome first time we've had you
on um Bassam mus have very fired up I
mean a lot of people who are pro
Palestinian historically are very fired
up about this tonight as we came on air
this as yet unverified in terms of who's
responsible but it's it the Hamas are
claiming uh that this is an Israeli air
strike on a Hospital May killed 500
people it comes back to proportion for
me what is the correct response to the
outrage of October the 7th I don't know
what the correct response is but I don't
believe that Israel would be stupid
enough to bomb a hospital the day before
Biden can I just say Israel has released
a statement already saying that they
warned civilians to evacuate the
hospital not true that's been that's
been taken down by Al jazer already it
wasn't true there's a lot of stuff
flying around there's a lot of people
putting videos they claim Hamas
misfiring a rocket others are saying
it's definitely Israeli I think we need
to wait for absolute Clarity on this
what is indisputable is a hospital has
been here and it appears hundreds and
hundreds of people have died it it feels
to me with President Biden arriving
tomorrow this is a bit of a gamech
changer yeah yeah which is why I don't
believe it was deliberate because it
just seems it just doesn't make sense
that they would do that but is it the
kind of thing which you would say that
if you're bombing the hell out of Gaza
and this happens is collateral damage
and you have to suck it up I don't think
Israel has ever targeted hospitals it
would always avoid hospitals if it
possibly could so no of course I don't
think that it's good to I mean Israel
has already targeted hospitals by saying
that it was shutting off power and water
which resulted in hospitals overflowing
with patients that were effectively
untreatable that was considered a war
crime many people have called that out
was a war crime just to be clear the
Reuters news agency is now reporting
comments from the Israeli military
saying its intelligence shows a
Palestinian Islamic Jihad group is
responsible for the hospital attack at a
rocket barrage from Gaza intended for
Israel pass near the Gaza hospital and
is hereit we don't know you we don't
know let's talk about what we do know
shall we okay we know that the Israeli
state has committed war crimes we know
that they have instituted a basically a
regime of collective punishment we know
now that they've used white phosphorus
in uh civilian areas which is considered
a war crime we know that this comes on
the back of the brutalization for many
many years now of the
Palestinian
over already
6,400 Palestinians have died inations
with troops since 2008 including 1,400
children we also know that Hamas just
perpetrated one of the worst Terror
attacks in modern history and the worst
attack on Jewish people since the
Holocaust and so I can answer your
question I can answer your question
about proportionality because
international law tells us what the
answer is in relation to proportionality
it tells us that we have a right to
defend ourselves it tells us that we
have a right whilst defending ourselves
to ensure that the outcome is Ultimate
peace and that is what as far as I'm
concerned we have not witnessed even in
the minute that we've been on and if and
if we were to ensure that the rule of
law was applied which is what I hope Joe
Biden is going to be um reinforcing when
he visits and when Rishi sunak visits I
hope that that's what they're going to
reinforce this is quite clearly though
not what many people within the Israeli
government want one Israeli Minister
said that he wanted to unleash a second
NABA do you guys know what that means
you know what the NABA was right the
official position of the Israeli state
for a long time has been there was no
NAA there was no catastrophe this didn't
happen this foundational Act of VI
violence that really led up in many ways
to the conflict we're seeing today to
Min is's minister of National Security
Ben says are the only thing that should
enter Gaza until the hostages are
released are hundreds of tons of
explosives from the Israeli Air Force
not an ounce of humanitarian Aid now
that strikes me as a statement which
doesn't care about international law
clearly clearly right benav is apping
and problem isn't the problem Netanyahu
has he's packed his cabinet for
political self expedience
he's packed the cabinet with a bunch of
right-wing Headbangers say stuff that
have' been saying stuff like this for a
long time this year absolutely and that
has a part of the reason why this has
happened um but you can't blame Israel
again for what Hamas did it's again
people trying to justify Palestinians
all Palestinians for what Hamas has done
that is what many actually we've seen
now IDF soldiers we've seen people
saying this is a war with Palestinian
civan do you agree that hamash should be
removed P piss you know my answer to
that question and it's so frustrating
the way that whenever anyone comes on
these show and talks about the
horrendous loss of life that has been
inflicted on Palestinian for many many
years there this idea there's this idea
that you can ask this question should we
condone Hass should we condone should we
condone Hass and what that does should
be removed breaks of course Hamas should
be removed nobody seriously doubt as
soon as you respond to the question I
said Israel has committed more crimes
and you respond by saying should should
we R the implications
SYM my question is how do you remove
them what you okay well what do we know
about Hamas we know that actually
Netanyahu has said in the past that he
wanted to strengthen Hamas because that
was the only way that he could ever get
rid of the Palestinian State he has said
that outright we have evidence that he
knew about these Terror attacks shinb
knew about these Terror we have we have
evidence that shinb said this was an
immense intelligence failure and that
was there was Intelligence that
suggested that this was going to happen
there's there's no question
would allow this to happen to his people
there is absolutely no way that's a
conspiracy theory the head of shin as
said this was an extraordinary askary as
a Jewish person yeah this has been a
nightmare 10 days yes but as a
Palestinian person right now in Gaza
they're going through if they're an
innocent Palestinian civilian they are
going through utter hell too do you feel
empathy for them I feel absolute empathy
for them and all the Jewish people I
know nobody wants Palestinian people to
suffer nobody does we want to get rid of
Hamas and we want our hostage is back
and so to answer P's question how to
remove remove her mask is it going to
happen by a ground wall
is that is the only way you can possibly
do it but the consequences could be
disastrous we've got to leave it there
we run out of time thank you all very
much indeed that's it for me whatever
you're up to keep been uncensored good
[Music]
night